welcome to history we've been hearing
electro series titled exigencies from
permanent emergencies to enduring
exceptions and today we are going to
cover Lee thank you so much it's a it's
a particular treat for me to be
introduced by you
we've pepper Lee was a graduate student
in history at Columbia where we the
question was it's about 15 years ago and
Beverly said long time ago and I said
for a historian right anyway here we go
let's let's turn from that subject to
James Madison
perhaps Madison ruminated in May 13 1798
letter to Jefferson it is a universal
truth that the loss of Liberty at home
is to be charged to provisions against
danger real or pretended from abroad
some security threats may be as Madison
put things pretended as in the border
emergency declared by the current
President of the United States
but there can be no doubt about the
realities of atomic weapons or even
active terrorism fresh circumstances
have placed great pressure on
constitutional constraints on the edges
of law and on the distinction between
the temporary and the permanent
circumstances these circumstances invite
us to identify steadying guidelines
yesterday's talk which some of you heard
trace the shift over the past seven and
a half decades from security
circumstances punctuated by sudden
unpredictable temporary emergencies to
the creation and enlargement of a
precinct of policy characterized by
permanent exceptions to ordinary
procedures at stake is less whether good
or bad decisions are made than the
character of liberal democracy and its
capabilities this zone this zone of
exceptions has grown we're security
cloaks the mechanisms of open political
life and where decisions are not
constrained by ordinary democratic
institutions and constitutional
limitations with this transformation and
conditions a new constellations
combining episodic emergencies with an
expanding sphere of exceptions we are
confronted as Robert Dahl assiduously
argued in 1953 and you heard this quote
yesterday with a class of situations for
which the traditional democratic
processes are rather unsuitable and for
which traditional theories of democracy
provide no rational answer end quote
for Dahl the extent and intensity of the
non-democratic arena composed what i
designated as his nightmare war cold and
hot actual and anticipated even invented
had come to seem endless and has come to
seem endless as noted yesterday the
growth of a zone of exceptions has
advanced through law especially by
congressional delegations of authority
to the president and the executive
branch and through Article two claims by
presidents who issue executive orders
and declare emergencies the separation
of powers teeters already by 1973 the
legal scholar gerhard Casper was
testifying two hearings before the
special committee on the termination of
national emergencies he was testifying
that a perpetual sense of emergency
fosters and I quote a mentality which
suggests that we live in a garrison
state and that quote we are in a state
of alertness at all times there is no
such thing said Casper as normal times
anymore addressing the State Bar of
California in 1976 Idaho Senator Frank
church identified quote an insidious
threat to constitutional government in
this country the steady accretion of
power placed in the hands of the
President of the United States by
emergency statutes hastily enacted a
quarter century later later in remarks
to the Republican Governors Association
in late October 2001 Vice President
Cheney made clear quote that homeland
security is not a temporary measure just
to meet one crisis many of the steps we
have been forced to take will become
permanent in American life I think of it
said Cheney as our new normalcy
and early in his presidency Barack Obama
referring to 9/11 and al-qaeda noted
quote we know that this threat will be
with us for a long time and we must use
all elements of our power to defeat it
concurrently decision makers about
national security
security regularly witness members of
Congress being all too willing to
abdicate responsibility less they suffer
political consequences that is abdicate
responsibility about national security
politicians have few incentives to seem
weak on security and for citizens with
qualities of protection and basis for
judgment hard to comprehend
disorientation has become familiar at
what point we must ask to such
developments do more than preserve but
actually change the character of the
regime just this set of concerns
motivated Dwight Eisenhower's well-known
farewell speech of January 1961 speaking
of the quote conjunction of an immense
military establishment and a large arms
industry the president expressed quote
grave implications as our toil resources
and livelihood are all involved so is
the very structure of our society
eisenhower warned that we must guard and
i quote against the acquisition of
unwarranted influence whether sought or
unsought by the military-industrial
complex because he said the potential
for the disastrous rise of misplaced
power exists and will persist and he
further insisted quote as we want
democracy to survive for all generations
to come
not to become the insolvent phantom of
tomorrow we must never let the weight of
this combination endanger our liberties
or democratic processes it is possible
for the is it possible for this quest
Eisenhower's quest to succeed which if
any forms of response to long lasting
exigencies to permanent exceptions which
if any forms of response can be made
compatible with the moral and
epistemological commitments of
liberalism liberal thought about
exigencies
developed in adversary dialogue with
important thinkers who believed that the
good of security demands tough and
unitary nostrils this orientation
certainly characterized the astringent
views of Thomas Hobbes in the 17th
century and Carl Schmitt in the 20th as
a foil and as a stimulus each loomed
over the process of liberal creativity
when such thinkers is John Locke and
Alexander Hamilton called Friedrich and
Clinton Rossiter sought to counter
claims about the need to fashion a non
liberal Leviathan anti-liberal critiques
regarding exigencies most notably that
of Schmitt have been revived recently
often with great enthusiasm and
far-reaching new ones like that of the
Italian philosopher Giorgio Agamben have
been advanced placing advocates of
liberal democracy on the defensive as
persisting exigencies and precipitous
emergencies requiring urgent judgment
and discretion have come to be entwined
with what Dahl and his contemporaries
that I cited yesterday rightly
identified as an unprecedented arena of
enduring exceptions forty years ago the
student of comparative politics are in
lie part lamented how these matters have
been quote unjustifiably neglected for
many years it is amazing he commented
that so little thinking in writing has
been done on the politics of emergency
situations since the early scholarly
efforts of Carl Friedrich Clinton
Rossiter and Frederick Watkins and of
the even earlier work of the German
jurist Carl Schmitt and quote no longer
as many post 9-11 articles that sit in
multiple high piles on a large table in
my study at home attest
I've profited enormous Lee from this
body of work by historians of political
thought legal scholars
students of state making and the conduct
of international relations analysts of
Public Policy and more yet over and over
again I've been frustrated in reading
this literature by the way this
scholarship is subdivided by how these
plentiful deliberations tend to be
segmented into quite separate
conversations what you read in the law
journals and read and political theory
and read in the IR literature are not
precisely not only not the same they
have almost very little to no overlap
such division was not the case say when
Locke Hamilton and other founders
addressed what might be called the
Hobbes challenge or when Friedrich
Watkins and Rossiter among other
liberals notably including Hans Kelsen
pushed back against Carl Schmitt by
contrast when agamben who's writing I
will discuss briefly next time when he
argued after 9/11 that with the zone of
exception having become the rule liberal
democracy had become irrelevant most of
the counter engagement with his ideas
has been limited to writing by other
philosophers and theorists who often
reprised the frequently arcane and
opaque qualities of his prose and
reasoning indeed not since the widely
attended debates both in the Academy and
the public realm during the mid-1950s
with regard to the controversial
propositions in the power elite by
Searight Mills has there been the kind
of multifaceted multi-layered accessible
conversation we urgently need not only
as scholars but as citizens to tackle
the questions at hand as I proceeded my
premise is that Dahl underestimated the
scope and depth of the problem the
problem he so acutely identified the
zone of enduring exceptions has not been
limited to atomic weapons nor can it be
found only to the side rather than
inside the main features of today
liberal democracies exigencies
emergencies and exceptions are entwined
as in a braid I'm keenly aware that the
uneven preliminary an incomplete
character of what I have been saying and
will continue to say will not address
many important issues I'm certainly not
going to talk today about the debate
about the problem of emergencies that
galvanized the United States for the
three decades before the Civil War nor
will I be discussing matters of
exception in post Civil War
reconstruction or in u.s. colonial rule
in Puerto Rico and the Philippines after
1898 what I do what I would like to do
is offer a down payment for what I hope
will be a more satisfactory account and
a fuller account when it gets into print
now Dahl and Eisenhower did not quite
search for a balance between liberty and
security that was a phrase used by last
well but I think it's not exactly right
rather each sought to achieve both
within a hierarchy of importance each
insisted that the demanding quest for
security is justified only when it's
geared to protect human freedom this has
been the orienting characteristic of
liberal views ever since Locke in that
spirit we might ask how should we
identify the ideas and craft the
institutional arrangements that best
protect desirable regimes yet restrict
and overbearing Leviathan ever since the
traditions founding moments thinkers we
have come to designate as liberal have
placed this question front and center
they're varied writings wrestle with the
wish to construct the government of
limits that nonetheless can facilitate
the ability to confront pressing danger
this search has never proceeded without
bearing in mind powerful disapproving
arguments as a significant example none
of the early anglo-american liberals and
we probably need to put liberals in
inverted commas because they didn't call
themselves liberals none of the early
anglo-american Liberals
was unaware of the great corpus of
Hobbes whose state of nature as we all
know a state of perpetual threat
impelled humans to create governments
and civil society's actions he wrote
they would not take quote in the absence
of fear which he beautifully defined as
the anticipation of future evil unlike
Locke's more irenic state of nature
which he contrasted to a state of war as
we all know that of Hobbes is one of
quote war and not simply war but a war
of every man against every man it is the
fear of not otherwise preserving himself
as he wrote in the conclusion of the
initial part of elements of law that
moveth a man to become subject to
another in a radical turn that in this
respect anticipated locke hobbes
identified exit from the state of nature
as a matter of popular sovereignty
notwithstanding his own preference for
monarchy he emphasized how a sovereign
people exercising constituent power to
exit from the state of nature is free to
choose any form of government not just
monarchy but aristocracy or democracy
quote the differences between
Commonwealth's he wrote into kirei are
derived from the difference in the
person's to whom sovereign power is
committed for Hobbes however this is
where the people's role must terminate
persons lose their natural ability
either in war by way of defeat or by
forfeiting it by way of a covenant to
gain security no matter which regime
type they choose the need for order
dictates that people yield their
sovereign right
all their sovereign rights but the
natural right to self-preservation
exclusively to those who rule this
transfer is voluntary collective
self-interested subsuming the good of
Liberty for the good of protection but
not without as I said a reciprocal
condition or implied or a reciprocal
condition as Hobbes famously wrote in
Leviathan the obligation of subjects to
the sovereign is understood to last as
long and no longer than the power lasts
if by which he is able to protect them
if for Hobbes sovereignty can quote be
hidden but not evaded and threats to
civil peace are so extensive that it
makes no empirical sense to limit or
divide powers not so of course for Locke
even when he made what at first blush
looks like a Hobbesian case for
prerogative power in his second treatise
on government stating the inherent
limitations of any legal framework and
of the lawmaking body itself when
situations demand resolution and speed
that chapter points to the quote many
things that the law can by no means
provide for discretionary executive
power is required to repeat Locke's
famous formulation I cited yesterday
prerogative denotes quote the power to
act according to discretion for the
public good
without the prescription of the law and
sometimes even against it this chapter
and the second treatise is vexing
precisely because elsewhere Locke's
liberal constitutionalism elevates the
rule of laws the Senate quinone of a
well framed government he also
identified the legislature the process
of political representation and
divisions of responsibilities between
executive and legislative locations as
underpinning political legitimacy yet in
the chapter on prerogative like Hobbes
Locke seems to reserve the power to
decide to the unconstrained
personal command of the sovereign for
this reason the political theorist
duncan kelly underscored how this deeply
statist designation of extraordinary
power frees the sovereign from the
bounds of constitutional legality
Parliament is sidelined even as Locke's
theory denotes the legislative as the
supreme site of a good regime
prerogative takes precedence in
circumstances of uncertainty better as a
result kelly argued echoing other voices
in the cambridge university tradition of
political thought not to treat Locke as
a prototypical liberal well my readings
much more conventional as a response
both to those who believe that
liberalism is not realistic about danger
and to those who believe that only non
liberal solutions to problems of
exigency can be effective Locke's
prerogative was neither unlimited nor
does it contradict his devotion to
parliamentary sovereignty
unlike Hobbes's fixed obsession for
security Locke was quick to insist that
prerogative power even when justified by
urgent and extreme peril must not be
arbitrary or boundless it is in play
only until the legislature can resume
its functions in Carl Schmitt later
language its purposes are Commissario
emergency powers exist only to protect
not replace a good regime politics
moreover is not perpetually in a state
of war executive power to act outside
ordinary procedures is both validated
and inhibited by principles that
proclaim the public good and the
preservation of society as the supreme
law the monarch is constrained in two
ways objectively by natural law and
subjectively by the trust and consent of
the people the executive must also be
restricted by toleration as Locke's
contemporaneous letter signified itself
an
to counter bustles and war in a
blood-soaked
Europe aggressors moreover are
identified not simply as enemies but in
normative terms as threatening the good
regime sovereignty is not freewheeling
in the manner of Schmitz later decision
ism but it's normatively and
procedurally grounded thus I believe to
be called deserves to be called liberal
should the crown violate these
strictures as you know Locke argued that
the people possess the right to rebel as
a conclusive check on predatory rule the
ultimate guaranteed whereas for Hobbes
there is no people outside the
constituted state only a crowd for Locke
the people within the law based regime
they founded is an independent moral and
political actor the most important one
thus while hobbes warned that if the
sovereign abuses power rebellion will
occur with the force and inevitability
of a natural disaster that is he made an
empirical prediction locke found this
formulation to be much too weak and
descriptive and insisted the people have
a right to rebel a right upgraded in the
declaration of independence to a duty to
rebel even as Locke's treatise including
the right to revolution inspired
America's founders many at that moment
were skeptical about his treatment of
prerogative powers particularly its
stark exceptional qualities the
anti-federalists were keen to construct
a political order without such
exceptions Thomas Jefferson sought to
limit the range of exceptions to actual
times of war not to a broader range of
possibilities James Madison who was
distressed 'full distrustful and
hesitant about Laxus limitations on
legislative power in emergencies
declared quote the chapter on
prerogative shows how much the reason of
the philosopher was clouded by the
royalism
of
Englishman and quote even Alexander
Hamilton an advocate of a strong
executive did not wish prerogative power
to be checked only by virtue and the
right to rebel
starting from explicitly Republican
premises in short America's founders
even while disagreeing about
constitutional details and meaning
individually and collectively sought to
identify institutional mechanisms
including means to constitutionalize
executive power more systematically than
Locke had proposed the framers
understood that the problem of emergency
was far from abstract the young United
States faced recurring threats to its
safety from global geopolitics from
Native Americans from internal
insurrections by both white citizens and
slaves quote to meet the exigencies of
the Union in Hamilton's view was among
the principal purposes he wrote that
necessitated the founding and the 1787
Constitution
thus he as well as Madison and John J is
co-authors of Federalist Papers called
for sweeping federal powers authorized
but not wholly within the ambit of the
Constitution observing that excision
exigencies often cannot be delineated in
advance or addressed by regular
lawmaking Federalist 23 as we saw
yesterday endorsed a form of prerogative
power quote free of constitutional
shackles given the infinite variability
of circumstances Hamilton insisted quote
this power ought to be coextensive with
all the possible combinations of such
circumstances end quote
but not without significant safeguards
recognizing the need for exceptional
powers as a stubborn dilemma for
constitutionalism Hamilton underscored a
key provision in the Constitution for
institutionalizing means to address this
dilemma
provision that limits the appropriations
of money for military purposes to the
period of two years
Hamilton knew that when the Roman Senate
had declared states of emergency it had
held on to the budget defending a
constitutional demand for the periodic
consideration and revision of military
expenditures he highlighted the checks
provided by quote the spirit of party
and fear of federal encroachment that
would make renewed support for the
military and I quote again a favorable
topic for declamation and vigorous
public debate and quote more generally
even hamilton stressed the importance of
congress in this domain and repeatedly
pointed to the legislative consent to
legislative consent as a precondition
for harmonizing state power with
legitimacy and synchronizing governing
capacity with freedom it was Congress he
insisted and I quote that is the
essential and after all the only
efficacious security for the rights and
privileges of the people which is
attainable in civil society and quote
yet like Locke Hamilton also understood
that just as the parameters of emergency
cannot be determined in advance so the
efficacy of institutionalized responses
would come to depend on situational
factors as executive discretion is
contingent and impossible to constrain
directly by law extraordinary executive
power must be checked
politically both by other branches of
government and by the people
Federalist solutions were a combination
of institutions and political psychology
and shared values reconciling security
and freedom would demand constitutional
mechanisms to mobilize and draw on
political passions and dynamics
institutions they understood are not
self sufficient concrete policies and
outcomes would depend on norms and
motivations
prudence and judgment possessed both by
the people's representatives and by the
represented people this balanced view
produced consequences for the way the
capacity of the young United States was
organized arguably most important was
the creation of a military not quite
like any other small flexible and
capable as it protected an advanced
estate without fixed territory or
settled neighbors on each border the
country faced danger and opportunity
indigenous enemies to the west slave
societies and Mexico to the south as
well as the prospect of domestic slave
insurrections a Tory offshoot to the
north north and a key ocean for
protection and commerce to the east
how could these sites of exigency be
managed without building an armed force
that would threaten Liberty the answer
was to follow a model advanced by
President Washington and elaborated a
quarter century later by Secretary of
War John C Calhoun what Calhoun called
an expansive military a small
professional army led by well-trained
officers who could command mobilized
militias that swiftly would demobilize
after the end of a conflict the result a
form in a way of operationalization of
the roman model of dictatorship was the
existence of a mobile lean force that
did not excessively a pin
impinge on the liberal constitutional
order the balanced view of the founders
also influenced after mid-century how
Lincoln acted during the most severe
crisis in American history in Clinton
rosters view his presidency was quote
the paragon of all democratic
constitutional dictatorships one in
which Lincoln assumed on his own
initiative extraordinary powers
including as we all know his suspension
of habeas corpus these capacities
Lincoln derive from a broad construction
of executive competence
and commander-in-chief powers and from
unabashed encroachments upon Congress
including an 11 week period in which he
governed without the legislature raising
an army and navy for an undeclared war
moreover with the Emancipation
Proclamation he also claimed constituent
powers and assumed judicial authority
all this was justified post hoc before
Congress and the people and so ratified
as instrumental measures necessary to
win the war with appeals to necessity
and the gravity of the crisis Lincoln
defended both seizing extraordinary
power and exercising it with dubious
legality even on occasion expressly
against the law so doing he advanced the
location of executive power into what
previously had been the domain of
Congress the President of the United
States Harper's Weekly complained in
March 1863 and I quote has in effect
been created dictator with almost
supreme power over Liberty property life
a power nearly as extensive and as
irresponsible as that which is wielded
by the emperors of Russia France and
China and quote or should I say China
never won that was a joke yet Lincoln's
actions do not simply or exclusively
illustrate how under extraordinary
conditions a constitutional order might
need to be suspended or to be preserved
crucially Lincoln use the exceptional
circumstances of the conflagration and
the War Powers he believed they
conferred as an opportunity to bring the
constitutional system closer to its
aspirational norms Lincoln's purpose was
not merely to protect the Constitution
but to achieve it importantly Lincoln's
emergency politics possessed a clear
beginning
and a jagged but ultimately identifiable
end his assertive use of prerogative
power had a clear objective and a
recognizable timeframe moreover after
the war's initial 11 weeks the federal
government proceeded largely by doing
business as usual it conducted the
congressional elections of 1862 and 1864
and the presidential election of 1864
each of which put Lincoln's rule and
policies at risk
there was no overarching transfer of
powers to the executive from the
legislature instead as soon as its
chambers convened Congress challenged
presidential prerogatives and demand
that a share in them by authorizing most
future exercises of exceptional power
Congress responded to Lincoln's eleven
weeks of implicit dictatorship by
forming an investigation commission to
inquire into every aspect of the war
setting a vital precedent for the future
notwithstanding a few notable cases
Rossiter notes the freedom indeed the
license of the northern press suffered
no restriction whatsoever Lincoln's
presidency further invited and endured
vituperative criticism from within
Congress within the press and from many
American citizens it also experienced
the Supreme Court imposed limit after
his death when in 1866 as you know ex
parte Milligan found the application of
military tribunals to be
unconstitutional when ordinary civilian
courts were operating and the greatest
achievement of the war the abolition of
slavery was not left to stand as a
wartime measure but was ratified as the
13th amendment to the Constitution in
short from its beginnings political
liberalism answered Hobbes by
demonstrating that it could be possible
to operate within the international
arena of war and peace of Empires and
Quest's and of the most severe internal
disorder without unduly compromising the
Liberty that was understood to be
fundamental for the existence of decent
regimes viewing the problem of emergency
as a recurring and inevitable aspect of
sovereign state hood and political life
liberal thinkers and statesmen
acknowledged an irreducible need for
emergency powers while insisting on
limiting and checking institutions
together with Prudential judgment far
from simply technical and legalistic
early liberal constitutionalism was
normative deeply political and inventive
in creating institutional solutions that
placed in here intentions within a
constitutional framework governed by the
rule of law
thus they bequeathed the precious
endowment to us a repertoire of ideas
impulses and institutions about
exigencies and emergencies from which we
can draw if it was Hobbes who had been
the primary foil for early liberals it
was Carl Schmitt whose incisive and
assertive political thought most
challenged their successors in the 20th
century Schmitz critique of liberalism
played out in two dimensions a deep
disapproval of the capabilities of
parliamentary democracy and a rejection
of what he thought to be both the
straightjacket and hypocrisy of liberal
law as you know he reasoned as follows
as political sovereignty is the power to
decide such capacity resides in the
sovereign without the constraint of law
Hobbesian but as no liberal regime can
admit or make this reality visible
thought Schmitt such governments must
cloak their activities with phony
legality in simpler times Schmitt
conceded political liberalism might have
been adequate then large zones of life
including religion I'm quoting
culture education and the economy he
argued did not pertain to the state and
politics but no longer across all modern
regimes irrespective of their
institutional arrangements or normative
commitments there had developed he wrote
in 1932 quote a total state which
potentially embraces every domain this
results in the identity of state and
society and the growing irrelevance of
Parliament and the separation of powers
a decade earlier
Schmidt had designated the crisis of
parliamentary democracy as not as much
caused by active Bolshevik and fascist
competition as by inherent internal
problems in a world requiring decision
by executives parliamentary debate had
become he thought purposeless and banal
a poor facade he wrote in 1923
concealing the dominance of parties and
economic interests who collude behind
the scene liberal parliamentary
democracy on this view had become a
system of illusion and incapacity that
had quote I'm quoting Schmidt again lost
its moral and intellectual foundation
and only remained standing through sheer
mechanical perseverance as an empty
apparatus end quote
liberalism for Schmidt had nowhere to go
but out in reviving and orientation much
like that of Hobbes and by advancing the
importance of the exception as the key
instrument an indicator of sovereignty
Schmidt argued that quote the liberal
constitutional state represses the
question of sovereignty by a division
and mutual control of competences
faithfully and I'm continuing to quote
the question of exception wrote Schmitt
stands outside the rule of law the
exception he wrote is not codified in
the existing legal order rather it is
response to extreme peril a danger to
the existence of the state that cannot
be circumscribed factually and made to
conform to a preformed law and quote
thus only decisions about exceptions
rather than ordinary policy choices
Schmitt insisted our decisions quote in
the true sense of the word with this
underpinning present problems of
enduring exception can be posed in terms
elaborated by Schmidt's book
dictatorship which surveyed the
institution from the Roman paradigm to
the emergency provisions of the vie Mar
Constitution famously the books typology
distinguished Commissario and sovereign
forms of dictatorship a distinction
itself rooted in Roman law exemplified
by ancient Rome the Commissario type is
strictly bound by time and carefully
defined tasks its powers are
constitutionally constrained most
important it is intended to maintain the
existing order the sovereign form by
contrast liberated from constitutional
constraints and associated with the
people's unified constituent power is
unlimited in time and boundless in task
as itself the great exception it is
characterized and I quote by principally
unlimited Authority which means the
suspension of the entire existing order
rather than preserve it operates outside
the existing legal system breaks with
existing norms and institutions and aims
to transform the regime and move history
forward by creating holy novel forms of
government propelled by the idea of
predestined progress this form of
dictatorship for Schmitt represented
quote the culmination of the modern
historical trend toward totally
unrestrained political action totally
unrestrained
little action the precise inverse of
liberal constitutionalism that limits
rulers and specifies both who may act
and how they may act conceptually and
historically exceptions schmidt argued
had proved to be in commence herbal his
word with the rule of law and legal
rationalism which he took to be the
essence of liberalism continuous
emergencies are bound to undermine the
liberal order Commissario dictatorship
moreover could no longer succeed because
the modern world was different after the
political ascendance of radical
especially soviet notions of political
legitimation because managing an
exceptional situation through law
usually entails stretching the letter of
the law to comprehend cases that are in
manifest tension with it he reasoned the
very insistence on addressing exigencies
through law inevitably eviscerates or
hollows out the rule of law the result
is an exercise of arbitrary power under
the pretence of legality dictatorial
powers first delegated as Commissario
become sovereign the regime is
transformed from within for Schmitt this
result the result he preferred offers
the bonus of unmasking liberal hypocrisy
this view is not unfamiliar today it's
been a huge revival of Schmidt in the
Academy and outside Schmidt's advocacy
quickly was recognized as a poison pill
for liberal democracy his seductive
writings posed sharp analytical and
situational challenges for his
generation of liberal thinkers who like
Schmidt sought to grapple with
exigencies in the trying circumstances
of the 1920s and especially the 1930s
and 1940s it became imperative for
liberals to
grounds on which to answer especially to
place problems of emergency and
exception not outside but within the
rule of law as realists reeling from the
crises than the collapse of the Weimar
Republic and the rising tide of
totalitarian dictatorships a
constellation of critics of Schmitt that
included Harvard's call Friedrich his
student Yale's Frederick Watkins and
Cornell's
Clinton Rossiter revisited and
elaborated a liberal approach to
emergencies within the restraining
qualities of law their theoretical and
policy ideas were designated to counter
Schmidt's diagnosis of liberalism as
incapable further like Locke and the
founders they insisted that the
political community does not exist
outside law but is constituted through
law captured by the title of raza ters
constitutional dictatorship their
solutions a short term concentration of
authority consistent with adherence to
liberal constitutional government was
insistently comma serial resurrecting
the roman model the anti Schmidt
liberals explored the character of
temporary abrogation whose central aim
is to protect the constitutional order
such quote dictatorship they believed
could be updated and made workable
precisely because leaders and liberal
democracies are embedded within and
answerable to democratic norms and
practices working with the assumption
that a fund of public virtue exists and
can be sustained by proper institutions
they believed that Algernon's
Sidney's conditions that I discussed
yesterday limited in time circumscribed
by law and kept perpetually under the
supreme authority of the people could be
secured by modern liberal regimes
drawing on the experience of the
democracies that fought World War one
and on empirical worth
examples of effective government whose
powers had been based on temporary
assignments to the executive branch by
legislators these scholars insisted that
there must be no departure from the rule
of law further they stressed delegations
had to be specific targeted and limited
in time only with such authority could
exigencies be governed with in a liberal
frame without such authority they
thought it would not be possible under
conditions of duress to safeguard the
standing and rights of citizens the core
intention of any liberal understanding
of law the exception must not become an
empty space from which norms are absent
these insights remain as excellent broad
guys cautious optimism characterized
that quest America's theorists of
emergency in the 1930s and 1940s
understood that Sidney's criteria did
not reduce the role the rule of law
simply to the letter but decisively
included the laws spirit its social
meaning and efficacy like Sydney they
believed in a commis aerial approach
that comprehends not just institutional
practices but mores and political
culture to be viable liberal
constitutionalism and thus any form of
constitutional dictatorship must draw on
and quicken the fund of civic spirit far
from simply legalistic or technical as
Schmitt had insisted their liberal
approach to emergency relied on a robust
public sphere and engage citizens
jealous of their liberties and capable
of collective action for this reason no
simple one-size-fits-all solution could
be possible Commissario exceptions these
thinkers believed always are contingent
on concrete circumstances ethical
horizons and political will refusing
legal extra legality as an acceptable
orientation those theorists also
rejected powder
of policy that could turn temporary
measures into the norm they proposed to
address not just national security but
other fear generating conditions within
law based political processes which
Rossiter as a skeptic concerning the New
Deal identified as a disproportionately
positive state the result of excessive
congressional delegation this outcome
guided Rossiter to a sweeping puzzle how
to proceed if Algernon Sidney's
conditions could be attained no longer
and as we saw that was precisely bob
dole's puzzle especially with temporal
limits removed might liberal norms and
values remain effective in the face of
lawmaking that was building exceptions
through legal delegations of power to
the executive in facing up to persisting
exigencies each generation of liberal
thinkers and actors in short sought to
secure Sidney's stipulations by
imagining timely institutional
arrangements and normative orientations
to confront security predicaments that
are hard to resolve the dilemmas and
enduring exceptions that underpinned
dollz nightmare from this vantage were
less entirely new than intensely
concentrated versions of long-standing
quandary for political liberals
unfortunately these dilemmas have become
more not less difficult because we have
moved beyond the challenge of
quantitative frequency to one of
qualitative permanence more difficult
for sure but not I will claim tomorrow
impossible to address thank you very
much
[Applause]
please when you ask your question just
raise your hand
this is Yael go ahead
which is curious about exigencies
emergencies and exceptions and I'm
curious about another word that often
comes up in these scenarios which is
crisis which if you look at the
political language the sort of common
political language that people in your
public sphere are usually talking about
they're often talking about a language
of crisis rather than these words so it
are these all identical terms do they
all mean the same thing different so
first I avoid the word crisis implicitly
obviously but deliberately crisis is
really whether one can read about the
history of the term of Reinhard
chrysella kimonos the brilliant essay on
the meaning of crisis but crisis in the
modern world has come to connote as a
kind of a something analogous to a
medical situation in which an illness
sudden crisis medical crisis hits and
either gets resolved or the patient dies
and that strikes me as a rather stark
binary in a now what do I mean by these
three terms then we'll come back Christ
by exigencies I use the term as Hamilton
did in the Federalist Papers and others
have as well simply to connote something
of persisting security challenges he
writes in the Federalist Papers about
you know we're separated by two oceans
everybody thinks the continent is is
secure it's really not secure because
after all the British of the world's
leading naval power the Spanish of
colonies right near by the the native
Indian tribes are more likely to ally
with them than with us because they have
more to fear from us than from them etc
etc and so we face a
a persisting set of exigent situations
and in in a sense I'm trying to use
though I don't know that this the word
exigencies will survive into print form
as a title a little too arcane but the
main mean to imply that
of course any modern state including
liberal states faces exigencies of
security either actual or potential it
comes from being inside a state system
the okay so much for exigencies
emergencies connote as situations are
now like a crisis but things that happen
in an unforeseen sudden unpredictable
urgent way that require at least seemed
to demand quick solution and it's that I
think was from lock forward the dominant
way of thinking about what happens the
exigencies are long-term and kind of
permanent but emergencies pop up in
different ways
an unexpected invasion occurs or someone
and broadly speaking until the mid late
and let's say I'll go with doll on this
and say until the atomic bomb it was
understood by liberal and non liberal
states alike that when they faced
emergencies they would be dealt with and
there'd be a beginning a middle and an
end some emergencies like crises might
really threaten the end of the whole
regime but some emergencies or
emergencies without being full crisis
like in them in a medical sense but then
said doll and his essay I'm gonna if I
can let's see if I can I have a slide up
here let's see if I cannot not how do I
get to the next
the only two slides ones that I don't
know if there's a keyboard it's got an
arrow let's just look at that oh I'm a
technical wizard he this was dull as a
plain statement of fact the proposition
is scarcely debatable the political
prophecies of democracy do not operate
effectively with respect to atomic
energy to say so much is not to pass a
moral or practical judgment the
difficulties that so few of us can
remember the consequences so far the
control of such decisions as a kind of
indigestion element in the operation of
American democratic politics in this
respect the atomic energy operation
aptly symbolizes opportunities popular
control of dwindled atomic ampion now
the last sentence atomic energy appears
to be one of the growing class of
situations one of a growing class of
such the traditional democratic
processes are rather unsuitable and for
which traditional theories of democracy
provide no rational answer that's quite
a you know in in tone under like a
statement an article how many in the
room has ever read this article 1953
quite remarkable has ever ever I'm in a
class room so I can administer questions
how many who's ever read I mentioned
yesterday 1984 lectures by Bob Dole
published as a book on new on
controlling nuclear weapons his 1984
lectures at the University of Syracuse
Syracuse University anybody read that
book I bet nobody now Bob Dahl was one
of the most widely read theorists of
democracy anywhere anytime he was the
genius of them are genuinely the
arguably the leading political scientist
of democracy certainly in my lifetime
and this work on atomic power on
exceptions it's an exception to the
normal democratic processes is something
that
been either forgotten neglected and so
on but it raises that article that
little article six pages long was the
inspiration for these talks when I read
that article it's one of these things
you have a kind of even read something
you have a visceral reaction to first of
the Bob doll and then I thought this is
just when he's writing a preface to
democratic theory in which he's telling
us about polyarchy and polyarchy is a
regime in which multiple minorities not
a single majority govern and in which
citizens he tells us in a polyarchy um
always have access to the political
arena but not here
not after the Atomic Energy Act and
other kinds of stuff so I use exceptions
in the Dalian sense as referring and of
course the Schmitt had used that term
and others had used that term but but
I'm using it in the sense of exceptions
to the what he calls the traditional
democratic processes and so we have an
arena and that arena it was the the
thrust of what I wanted to say and my
sort of mostly descriptive lecture
yesterday has gotten bigger and bigger
and bigger it's not a even that that
list I read of both declarations
executive of emergency declarations or
assertions of capacity by the President
and the long list even in a period of
polarization of a legislative
productivity in the area of national
security
has created and and activities within
the bureaucracy like the NSA of
telephone call surveillance and so on
has create a much larger zone than
Robert Dahl feared when he was initially
writing and did not could not have
anticipated it's it's scale which raises
questions not just about whether or not
this zone is outside of democracy
but how if at all as Schmidt said it
would and I don't agree you'll see next
time with Schmidt but wouldwould so
imbricate and become in interconnected
with the normal processes of democracy
as to hollow them out and make liberal
democracy essentially illiberal and and
only masked by the hypocrisy of of the
rule of law which is said to be the rule
of law that no longer exists and this
also in a different way was Eisenhower's
nightmare it both in his first inaugural
and in his farewell speech if you read
Obama's first speech at the National
Archives on security he articulates
something of the same worry I'm now not
judging how well either Eisenhower or
Obama did in this in this respect and
then you have presidents or their
advisers John you for for bush or the
intellect who now occupies the White
House himself who who are not really
worried at all about and sees unitary
powers views of the presidency they're
not they're not worried about separation
of powers questions or about really
about liberal constitutionalism so it's
that zone of exceptions that I think we
very badly need both normative clarity
about and policy imagination about and
in a very not wholly satisfactory way I
warn you because it's a really hard set
of questions I'm trying to think about
and only in a preliminary way try to
address some of that tomorrow so you
know what do we do in the consequences
and how do we how do we deal with a
contemporary theorists of exceptions
like Agamben who says well beyond
Schmidt
the game's over you know not a question
of a nightmare by Democrats there's
there's there's no recourse anymore the
zone of exceptions is so fundamental
that there's nothing to be done well if
that's true god help us all
and if it's not exactly true then how do
we navigate that reality of exceptions
that's a long-winded answer to a simple
story not a simple question but a simply
put the REC question yes your your to
your parent charge you write down of
these remain the same so in office
concedes that there's going to be a
realm of discretionary activity it tries
to as you mentioned yesterday a set of
incentives and interests that will
condition and limit the behavior of the
office holder I can't guarantee
conditions the behavior and I think the
reason that job for example and it
doesn't see offices as resources is that
his political science was behaviorist in
it discounted the importance of offices
but I don't see why we need to follow in
that tradition because it seems to me
that the alternative is to think of
constitutionalism mainly as rules and
therefore the problem is mainly
exceptions to rules but the idea of
offices explodes that framing because
I've concedes from the beginning that
rules don't apply themselves laws don't
execute themselves there is you know a
prosecutor with discretion for example
to execute a law or an executive and so
there's always this question of judgment
and froggit of and so on within even the
rule part of little constitutionalism so
the real question is how you can have
different sized domains your discretion
according to the needs of politics of
the era so it may be that in the atomic
era you know we need a constitutional
imagination
I can construct the right kind of office
to deal with that kind of problem and
yet provide popular judgment of the
decisions made and that might require
you know a new sort of office that
wasn't imagined in the 1700s but but the
idea of an office itself might be
helpful oh yeah so I think that's
enormous ly helpful thank you and the
you know I said yesterday I think if
someone asked you what I am I'm an
institutionalist I don't think norms
free-floating or law free-floating it
can be the answer it has to be
instantiated in in institutions that
provide complexes of not only
inducements and incentives but also in
inducements and incentives not to do
things as well as to do things you said
something in passing which i think is
incredibly important and certainly was
important and taken as tacitly important
by all the figures I mentioned namely
that liberal democracy is particularly
good at leadership transformation in a
peaceful way there will be a judgment
made on its a retrospective judgment on
officeholders in a recurring way whether
every two years for the house or six
years for the Senate or four years for
the president and you may also have as
we have for the presidency and ultimate
term-limit that if you would ask you
know which two things does liberal
democracy do especially well that other
regimes don't do peaceful transition of
leadership would certainly be one and
the second would be the the
provisionality of policy decisions so
that the the group that's out can come
back peacefully and make different
policy judgments the the question it
seems to me one way to rephrase the
problem
of exceptions is to ask to what extent
do they is that zone called the Dalian
zone enter into those two key
formulations to what extent for example
notwithstanding the peaceful transition
a you you we liberal regimes have
created permanent institutions and
constituencies example might be parts of
the intelligence community or the NSA in
terms of surveillance that transcend the
publicness of office and that second
therefore the provisionality of policy
is right not really up for discussion
and debate and you'll see if you're hit
tomorrow that some of the norms and
institutional arrangements I want us to
at least think about try to have the
force of preventing those two outcomes
but I really like very much the the
notion of thinking harder about about
office and offices of course commonality
with incentives but also with the rules
and if in a system of multiple offices
sometimes they check each other or can
oversee each other either so thanks you
know identify yourself
historian I guess your historian the I
just wanted to ask you about your
putting dial up you know but you're sort
of you know I'm not looking within what
this idea of atomic energy and
management of atomic energy and I wanted
to ask you about there's a group of
writers particularly Marcus Raskin who
produce the body of literature about
what they called the national security
state yep and particularly Raskin but
and also Daniel Ellsberg is involved in
this I mean a little red book by Daniel
Ellsberg I guess it's going secrets yeah
where he talks about his personal
experience with people you know making
American policy I mean Ellsberg is
essentially saying that the things that
dot all is afraid of are almost were
almost entirely created by American
management of its atomic weapons and
what it forced other countries to do by
the atomic weapon Center but I mean the
just about the national security state
there is an argument that on most of
what you're talking about is due to the
fact that the national security state
has developed within the government and
it has persisted in our beginning of the
late 1940s there's also an argument
about the exposures of Edward Snowden
which suggests that the national
security state is stronger and bigger
and more dangerous than it has ever been
and that one was essentially done is to
take the internet and the modern forms
of communication and turn them into a
danger that's bigger than atomic
and that I mean I think you don't really
you don't want to get into the head okay
well I'm just I just want to ask you
about but in different why did that be
discussed but in different language I
think you're reprising my talk of
yesterday which was to say that in the
atomic arena and beyond it what Dahl was
calling a zone of exceptions grew and I
think eisenhower himself uses the
language of the military-industrial
complex worried about its depth and
permanence it's not just Institute for
Policy Studies my old friend Raskin who
did it or and others who were in the new
left which I would certainly numbered
myself the critique of of the security
state has many interlocutors and
understandings from Rand Paul to the
left you know however that doesn't make
it right or wrong but it seems to me the
the reason for doing it and I'm saying
this you can put a question mark after
each of my declarative sentences the
reason for doing it through wearing the
glasses as it were the lenses offered by
a significant a figure democratic theory
combining theory and empirics is Dahl is
that it gives us a way of asking
questions about the core of democracy
that the national security critics
whether Ellsberg or others don't quite
ask because what what they don't do is
link that critique directly into making
constitutive of a larger theory of
liberal democracy and many of them not
all of them but some begin to be the
reason so many on the Left have come to
like Schmitt and Argonne Ben is they
identify with the critic they create a
critique so deep as to leave no room
left for liberal democracy so yes I
agree with the part of that literature
that says this has been a wider and
expanding scope the size
but where you'll see that I stopped is
in thinking that therefore we simply
have to say the games up that security
state is the state and has taken over
it's interesting go back a long way to
seven eight decades the see right mills
power elite which is one of the first
really brilliant book a difficult book
in some ways annoying book but uh but a
brilliant book which says America for
its big decisions is governed by an
elite that is corporate military and
political and a very small number of
people make these decisions but even
even see right mills does not say that's
all that counts he then says there's a
huge range of decisions he called middle
range decisions which in effect is every
other policy but national security and
the only examples Mills gives of see of
a leaked decisions are dropping the bomb
on Hiroshima going to war in Korea and
deciding not to go to the aid of the
French and yen Bien Phu who made those
decisions he says a small elite I
wouldn't I wouldn't say AHA that's the
zone of exceptions I think there is the
decision to drop a bomb on Hiroshima for
M not now arguing right or wrong could
not possibly have been a decision taken
through quote normal democratic
processes and debate that there may be
some substantive decisions that either
require speed or secrecy that cannot be
normalized and of course this was the
middle of a world war that we're talking
about here the but what I would be
closer to Mills than to to Raskin for
example in asking about how we want to
think and certainly closer to doll in a
implicitly in dolls case and asking how
want to think about this zone which
Schmitt and argon bends would say it was
not a zone of exceptions anymore it's
it's the rule how we would want to think
about that zone in relationship to the
larger regime to which it's connected
and and within which its embedded I at
least want to leave that as open
questions so you know I I'm very glad
that we know a lot more than we did know
about surveillance state for example we
probably would not have known without
Snowden but that doesn't mean that the
conclusion that follows is that it has
so overwhelmed everything else that we
no longer have a liberal democracy at
all
which is the Agamben position
I guess two questions so curious about
what you think about the politics of
this moment in which to some degree that
national security state or at least the
intelligence agencies are actually being
seen as the kind of protectors of
democratic norms and but I'm also
curious because you're telling I guess
this is a historical question you're
telling a story about things that tend
to move in one direction right this is a
story of the worth of exception the
growth of emergency powers clearly a lot
of this concentrated in the executive
and I just wondered historically if
there are moments that you can point to
that our moments of effective and
straight or pushing back on that I
suppose I think of a moment like like
maybe the 1970s in which some attempts
are made to put some set of new rules
around this but in your own historical
imagination is this really just a story
that goes in one direction the
inexorable growth or are these moments
are there moments of interesting contest
successful constraint I'm pushed by it
make sense of these great questions as
it turns out I have a very considerable
privilege this tournament I'm teaching
this term and last there's a group of
young members of the Columbia University
community called Obama scholars and they
won a global competition there are 12 of
them they're 400 500 applications and
they come from everywhere from India
Zimbabwe Paraguay Colombia France
etc and they they all run NGOs were
founded then they're between 28 and 45
years old and and they wanted a year in
a university to reflect and one of the
issues they continuously reflect on is
the question of the boundary between
security and its urgencies and what they
hope would be their country's better or
more decent regime so if you come from
Vietnam you live in a one-party state if
you come from Paraguay you have
something of a history of dictatorship
you have to reckon with if you come from
the Cameroon which is in the throes of
civil war right now and battles between
Anglophone and francophone people and so
on and so this set of issues is not
limited to liberal democracy but part of
it and one of the issues that recurs in
our conversations or in their
conversation has to do with your first
question which is what kind of a
security establishment is it possible to
have that would protect the values of a
decent regime as opposed to being
predatory right and you know isn't it
ironic that in the age of I'll say the
name Trump we look to Central
Intelligence for to protect us
especially for some of us who when we
had more hair it would have found that
inconceivable I should say the
co-teacher
I have in this class is a very mature if
ik brilliant international lawyer named
of real Haines who was President Obama's
deputy national security adviser and for
two years the deputy director of the
Central Intelligence Agency so maybe
I've been whitewashed or something we're
having a brain wash not whitewash
the but what strikes me what what I've
taken away from listening to her
interactions with those questions and
these global students is how much of a
range there is within the intelligence
community about considerations of these
issues that is it's not just a simple
homogeneous bunch so you know a John
Brennan as director of CIA is not
necessarily the same as Pompeo as the
head of the CIA and the but underneath
it you like almost any big bureaucracy
you have apparatchiks who who were told
what to do they do it whether it's I
love the ink of the English of a phrase
for subversive activities sneaky biggies
whether they perform you know
sneekybeeky or they do analysis there's
a kind of permanent civil service there
and the norms that I'm prepared to
believe I'm not an apologist for many
things that have happened in the Obama
years but people who were appointed in
lead positions in key agencies including
Central Intelligence did have a kind of
commitment to democratic and liberal
norms that one doesn't always find at
the top of those agencies and you find
they're the ones now testifying in
Congress speaking out saying they're
appalled that the violations they're
seeing but there's a very difficult to
identify and police boundary between the
core tasks they're given of protect the
American people without many constraints
without many procedures without much
oversight
without need to budget report to
Congress in the normal way and so on and
so forth and and their own normative
commitments because institutionally they
face very few constraints and that's
part of dolls problem
are there pushback examples well
yesterday actually I spoke a bit about
the 70s and the church a period and of
course the House voted yesterday under
the terms of the 1976 act on emergencies
to reject the president Trump's
declaration of emergency the Senate
likely will have a majority to do the
same he'll then veto and then there
won't be an override but the under the
terms of the 76 act is I think we may
have talked about yesterday
the once once the the legislative veto
had happened the president would have
had no come back only because the
supreme court ruled in 1983 that this
was unconstitutional can trump now veto
a rejection of his emergency by the
House and the Senate
so the push there was a real pushback
moment I think her other point I mean
today I talked about Lincoln I actually
think that following the 11 weeks there
was a kind of institutional reassertion
of Congress of normal elections of a
free press of all kinds of challenges
and ultimately the need to
constitutionalize the emancipation of
the slaves that's a push back and I
think it's an instructive one and I also
think that I think of book you know well
I'm Michael Hogan's book on the making
of the national security state in the
late 1940s crossable cross of iron I
think it's cool right yeah
because we could rerun oral exams the
where Hogan says if you actually look at
the security state that was fashioned in
the 40s much of it was a compromise
between those who said any security
state is going to be a threat to Liberty
and many Republicans particularly took
that position and those who wish the
stronger security state so when
President Truman proposes universal
military training the UMT it's rejected
by Congress and we got a more ordinary
conscription and he's book is full of
examples of how when put to debate in
the democratic process the national
security state even at a moment of
ascension when an atomic energy act and
national security act are being passed
there's some degree of restraint put
into into the system so yes there are
such examples I think broadly speaking
the the trend has been that but with ups
and ups and downs it seems to me the
question for us is not any simple push
back and saying we don't want anybody to
protect our security or quite apart from
anything else who the hell will govern
nuclear weapons but the what I think we
do know do badly need and this I'll
speak to our sets of norms and
institutions that come at three
different moments before an emergency
during a period of duress and post-hoc
in terms of retrospective judgment and I
think we're missing all three presently
and only by attending to all three can
we attend to what's outside the the
ordinary processes said Dom finally I
put back up Algernon Sidney this is 1680
as I said yesterday he lost
head for writing the sentence so we
should respect it I mean it was a act of
bravery grants a power liked to the
these referring to the Roman
dictatorship limited in time
circumscribed by law and perpetually on
the supreme authority of the people well
part of what I've said is that some
things are not limited in time but we
ought to think about how we act as if
they are circumscribed by law and kept
perpetually ultimately under the
authority of the people and the question
I think we need to ask ourselves which I
hope to turn to tomorrow yeah I expect
to is how to take those principles and
and and contrast them to the views like
Schmitt and then Hagen Ben would say
none of that's possible anymore and see
what room for navigating or maneuver
remains to us and ask as political
actors as citizens as well as scholars
how might we try to promote that kind of
agenda good thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you